malgré les craintes liées au nouveau
coronavirus les chinois ont fermement
l'intention de festoyer pour le nouvel
an lunaire 3 milliards c'est le nombre
de déplacements que devrait effectuer
les chinois au cours des quarante jours
que durent les festivités dont le point
culminant est la célébration du nouvel
an le 25 janvier le nombre de voyages en
train et en avion devraient grimper de
8%
dix sept mille vols seront offerts
chaque jour mon pays et chiffre record
mais n'existe plus touristique tant que
le coronavirus ne gâchent la fête
déjà des agences de voyages n'offre plus
de services dans la région de roanne où
le virus a est clos mais des entreprises
profitent de la crise dont les
fabricants de masques respiratoires pour
lesquels il ya déjà une pénurie en 2003
la crise du sras avait coûté près de 50
milliards de dollars à l'économie
mondiale
[Musique]